the two things that I did in my life
that I would say were the most impactful
was uh first um learn how to meditate um
that gives me um an Equanimity that
helps a lot and then um thinking about
principles uh that whenever I would
encounter something um most importantly
painful things but anything that I would
um reflect on realities that happen and
my interactions with it and then I would
write down the principes so I started to
do that also in the company because I
needed to communicate with other people
why am I doing it what is this crazy
place like and why are we doing it that
way so I want to encourage people to do
that that's also why I put out a a
journal just recently A lot of people
asked me to U help them write their own
principles so I just put out a journal
so that's those are the things I'd
really want to encourage if people can
um I would encourage meditation and I
would also encourage the writing down
their principles